are you following the the story of
Adidas with Yeezy and uh uh who owns the
design who owns all of it Adidas to sell
shoes based on easy designs follow and
break with Kanye Adidas said it would
start selling shoes based on his designs
and a bit to rebound after scrapping the
lucrative partnership with musician and
designer Kanye West and that spawn won
the company's most successful product
lines Finance Chief harm all my
allheimer said the Sporting Goods giant
was assault owner of all the rights to
the existing products except for the
easy name so the only thing Kanye owns
is the name and that the company
intended to make use of those rights as
early as end of next year he said we own
all the IP we own all the designs we own
all the versions the new colorways so
it's rip it's our product we believe
there are interesting things coming to
fruition in 2023 that's where we're
working through so what do they do
here's an idea do you think Adidas
takes the design and goes and calls I
don't know uh a you know you only have
like 10 people to do Travis Scott do
they call a Jay-Z do they call guys like
that and say hey we want to call it
something else once we own all this
design since our cons you know the
buyers customers love it let's choose
your own name of the easy add to it or
are they just gonna name it an Adidas
brand uh and people gonna buy it and at
the same time what is Kanye going to do
leaving he can only use the name but the
IP and the shoes designs is not going to
be with them what do you think is ended
up happening here well let's start Pat
let's ask you a question I mean you're a
person of influence
um you're 50 Cent now okay
hey
um question for you how would you like
to be the face of the sneaker brand
50 Cent so you're going to take all the
easy stuff that everybody knows is Kanye
and because he's gone you're just gonna
put like my brand on it uh I don't know
if I'm into that I just can't see
personally and I'm projecting they're
like a little like Miss Cleo here
reading minds but I can't see a real
powerful brand person yeah wanting to
feel like they were the second choice or
the second here I just don't see that I
see I see it's probably going to be
internal branding making Eternal
branding and run like that because I
don't know how I don't know how you
convince somebody that's going to have
enough magnetism with a buying public to
basically be the replacement I actually
fully agree with you and by the way when
I think of hip-hop I think of Tom the
business 100 but I think of gangster rap
but I actually agree with my best friend
Harry
quoting a 1980s MC light over there
Young MC Young MC but this this brand is
so associated with Yeezy I don't see
another rapper no 50 Cent Travis Scott
Jay-Z whatever Amigos whatever you want
to do they're not just gonna be like yep
[ __ ] on yeah I got this thing what about
Kim Kardashian
[Music]
I see them on people's feet and I just
don't get it yeah they look ridiculous
no these doesn't look too bad yeah but
that's a cool looking shoe it's like
that I got the one the bottom one of
them green if you hit that one that's
what I rock bro I don't know Pat have
you ever put those on Pat no I have not
but here's a question this is not me I
couldn't wear stuff yeah yeah but but
like what I'm wearing right now on cloud
I could wear that for the rest of my
life I feel amazing on cloud to me is
the most comfortable shoes in the world
tennis shoes I wear I feel like I have
nothing on actually I don't have on
Cloud on right now [ __ ] what do you have
the man cannot lie no no no today I got
cold I got Kobe's on baby Ethan's gave
me this there's got some I got Kobe's on
those are sick but this as much as I
love these shoes it's very uncomfortable
yeah they're basketball they're for
basketball but I tell you here's the
part though here's a part though
um Adidas underestimated how much they
were gonna lose they lost more than they
people underestimated people not as woke
as they thought they were gonna and by
the way I don't buy Adidas tennis shoes
I think people who bought Adidas tennis
shoes many of them it brought an
audience that they didn't have before
100 okay Nike does have an audience that
they have don't get me wrong I think
Steph Curry's but Adidas or some some
players some people are with Adidas but
it's not the same so who's more likely
to succeed here here's a question for
you easy is it is it more likely for
Kanye to take the name elsewhere and be
able to create momentum maybe it'll take
him a year two years three years to do
that or is Adidas more likely to use
that design to get back to the numbers
they were doing who's more likely easy
what do you think I'd be easy well do we
know what the numbers are in terms of
what they put in terms of what they put
into it and what they got back out of it
not just how much they were paying him
one of the most successful we can pull
up the numbers if you want to pull it up
it's one of the most successful selling
uh that sounds crazy to me where are
these people wearing these shoes here's
what I'll say about time everybody wears
them yeah everybody works with it people
listen they're guessing Cali you know
don't forget exactly don't forget where
you came from people so why do people
listen to Kanye why I don't but why do
you listen to Kanye because of his music
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no ideology is you're wrong you
know that I actually do not listen to
Kanye at all I do not like his music
well you listen to Mexican trap music I
understand that but it's not like you
listen to Hip Hop I know but when I'm
trying to get to tell you is I I started
following calling you about my Jesus
after I saw what he stood up for and by
the way I'm not the only one my my wife
is on a Teddy show no she's not a Teddy
should trip a girl she's a high heel and
and I bought her use it she loves them
she wears them all the time because of
what he stands for wait some of us will
stand we'll bike racing because you're
the exception I don't understand why you
think there's so little of us in this
world I'm just saying that that Kanye
who's how about this let's just keep it
simple who's Kanye's base
who is it what do you mean his base like
if there's like Trump has a base it's a
bad guy clearly it's yeah it's just rap
fence okay exactly so you're not you're
an exception you're not the rule that's
his face I 100 agree so his base is
hip-hop rap that Community right okay
that's why they're listening to Kanye
they don't want to hear his gospel music
they're not trying to hear his ideology
they want to hear his music and there's
a whole famous saying like we want the
old Kanye we want the old Kanye because
they want the old [ __ ] Kanye who made
hits and not just does racist
anti-semitic remarks that's not why
people are tuning into Kanye you might
be more in tune with that but that's not
his base are you saying that are you
saying he's making racist anti-semitic
remarks are you saying that people are
saying that no I am saying he's making
anti-semitic remarks which one I mean
roll the tape Hoss what do you mean
there's nothing well [ __ ] name one
the Jews did this the Jews did this the
Jews did this they controlled in
Hollywood the ones they're controlling
is that a lie certain Jews is it a lie
are they the only people that control my
question is it is it a lot about this
all Mexicans do this all Mexicans
no Mexico he's saying all Jews do this
who runs the most drugs in the world
Mexicans do is that is that a is that a
bad State all Jews
no he did yeah it's a tweet he said I'm
going death Con 3 on the Jews not all
it's a very different thing bro Ricky
you're gonna live the thing is again
it's like you want to call out
individual did you see the conversation
he had with Lex Friedman yes of course
you did yes so did it resonate at all
with you bro like I said I'm more
appropriate to call out individuals who
did you wrong or groups of people no
individuals individuals okay so then
you're proving my point whether it's
Mexicans or Jews or Muslim Muslims or
Asians like any time you go after groups
okay I'll give an example that's a
problem in in when we buy our jewelry
Hispanics we say we buy it from the
Armenians or we buy it from the uh the
the Armenians or what's other uh
Orthodox Jews probably or the Jews yeah
and we're not saying oh I bought it from
John Joseph the Jeweler we're saying we
bought it from the Jews we bought it
from the Armenians it's just a way of
saying no you bought it from that Jewish
guy
who do you borrow Jews we have this
conversations
when you had the car who are you like
like uh okay Nelly like you say like you
asked the the the
African-American gang say who you buying
drugs from the Mexicans why do they say
the gangbanger gangbanger Mexicans
that's not what they're saying it's just
a way of saying something and you're not
that doesn't mean it's the whole group
that's just so again I buy it from the
Armenians downtown L.A that's just a way
of saying something it's just language
bro it's not that big of a deal but
there is a difference between Hector
who's buying drugs off the Mexicans and
that one guy versus Kanye who has a
massive voice and what he's saying and
what he's spewing so by the way I get
what you're saying by the way I'm not
denying it talk your [ __ ] I do not agree
that he should be silenced I might but
if Brands want to drop him Balenciaga
Adidas whoever that's their choice I'm
not denying what you're saying bro what
I'm just telling you is don't look
you're looking too much into that
because that's just what we say that's
just how you speak that's that's just
language you're not gonna sit there and
let me make a list of all the [ __ ]
people I'm gonna I'm talking about
that's not how this works bro who you
who you I [ __ ] with the Mexicans I [ __ ]
with the blacks that's just the way of
you talk that's the way we talk that's
just the way that's lingle that's
American lingo you don't gotta get all
crazy about that [ __ ] it's crazy
you know what I mean so my question
still hasn't been answered so who do you
think's going to be who do you think is
going to have more likelihood of I think
Kanye I think Kanye because like this is
how America Works he for that one week
everybody was like Kanye oh my God he's
in give him six months he'll be right
back bro Americans forget and forgive
some other [ __ ] will come up they'll
forget about it he'll he'll he'll get
what I mean he's still alive he's still
on Twitter on Instagram
yeah which he should be I do not think
he should be silenced and I'm Jewish and
he's okay so what all the craziness
taking place I believe future looks
right if you believe future looks bright
get your latest Future looks bright hat
of valuetainment it says future looks
right here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red our black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people wore it in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks Bright House especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody's saying future looks spread
toward your future looks bright hat
click over here and to watch the entire
podcast click here take care everybody
[Music]